قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت عادت الى الواجهه
مجددا وبقوه فتهديدات ميليشيا حزب الله
القاضي التحقيق في القضيه بتنحيته لم تؤخذ
على محمل الجلد حيث عاد القاضي طارق
البيطار باستئناف في مهامه بعد اكثر من
عام على تجميدها من محكمه التمييز التي
كانت تنظر بدعاوي المتهمين بالترشيد
لتنحيه البطاله القاضي بيطار استند في
عودته على مبدا فصل السلطات الذي يمنع
محكمه التمييز النظر بقرار مجلس الوزراء
الذي احيلت عبره قضيه المدفاه على المجلس
العدللي
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدين لعل الحدث الابرز بقرار العوده
للمحقق العدلي استعداده للادعائي على
مجموعه من الشخصيات السياسيه والامنيه
والقضائيه لتحقيق معها عليهم حيث افاده
على المدير العام الامن العام لواء عباس
ابراهيم والمدير العام امن الدوله لواء
انطوان صليبه الى جانب مدعي عام الدوله
ورئيس المجلس الاعلى للجمارك العميد اسعد
الطفيلي المجلس الاعلى للجمارك الدراسي
كما دعا على الوزيرين غازي زعيتر ونهاد
المشروع بالاضافه الى رئيس الحكومه السابق
حسن دياب هو قائد الجيش السابق
بشكل مفاجئ قاضي التحقيق في انفجار مرفا
بيروت طارق بيطار يوجهوتهما لشخصيه سياسيه
ابرزها رئيس الوزراء السابق حسان دياب
بتهمه القتل على القصد الاحتمالي والمدعي
العام وثلاثه قوطات اخرين ويحدد جلسات
الاستجوابهم في فبراير المقبل الدوله
وهرد على قرار الادعاء اعلن المدعي العام
التمييزي في لبنان غسان عويدات المطلوب
للتحقيق اعلن رفضه القرار قاضي التحقيق
طارق البيطار باستجوابه بقضيه انفجار
بيروت وفي رساله طلعت عليها العربيه تحدى
عويدات المحقق العجيب انفجار المرفق بدعم
ان يده مكفوفه عن التحقيق اي انه استبعد
عن هذا التحقيق